back to the Hans thing a lot of people
now dissecting these games they're
playing
and there are they're recently saying
like even Fabiano caruana one of the
best players in the world was on some on
his podcast yesterday basically saying
okay this is beyond my level saying out
of my league yeah what's that what's out
of your league you played for the world
championship kind of we get what we can
read between the lines right is it
possible that Hans is that level of
Genius is there like different
different kinds of Genius
like where one you could be out of each
other's League kind of thing
maybe in the case of Magnus it's
understanding of end games
it's just somehow he understands the
that last phase of the game and the
complexities and the problems he compose
better than anybody else so you can see
Magnus do
uh poor looking Moves In the End Game
or like moves that don't fit what seem
your gut says is would be the optimal
yes but also
it's not that you even think they're
right you you just might not even
consider them yeah because of
over-reliance on your own information or
even the computer that was what was
going on in game six
she kept doing things and kept playing
and kept finding play and posing those
questions that humans and computers
could not understand so he beat the
engine basically he could he wouldn't
have beaten the engine because they
would have defended Yan lost that game
in the 90s move psychologically he
thought the game was over so that
contributed computer would have defended
so by the by the time this podcast comes
out which I don't know would be in a
week or something like that I feel like
more will happen
let's see you're predicting engine how
does this Hans drama end
look let's look in um in three months
by the time we get to the next World
Championship let's say
what what uh this the what are the
options what are the possible let's
imagine let's not say like what the
probability is like what are the options
uh chess.com is forced to or agrees to
or
whatever to come up with a huge amount
of evidence of cheating in the past
uh or Hans comes out
what are the what can Hans do with this
so I'm uncomfortable with the general
make sure you could maybe update me on
this but there was a little bit of an
attack on him not a lot of an attack
that he's a cheater right without
evidence without clear conclusive
evidence physical evidence physical
evidence so all of those all right
that's the tricky thing yeah so like
that stuff we're talking about is beyond
my level
that starts being
um kind of intuitive circumstantial
evidence there's
the statistical evidence behind the
over-the-board games that he's played in
2020 2021 where the games match what's
called engine correlation more than
Magnus and many other top Grand Masters
combined
but that can be argued is because he was
very strong in playing weaker
oppositions so there's always kind of
this argument against statistics right
there's the fact that the guy who Magnus
name dropped Maxim bloogie loogie is a
chess Grand Master and he's even been I
think president of the US Chess
Federation I've played him in some Blitz
Games it turns out I wasn't even fully
aware of the extent of this he has been
banned from chess.com for cheating for
cheating have they actually have has him
and Hans actually worked yes so that was
why he named dropped that right that's
also not good you see where this is
getting
you still don't have the physical proof
but you have
smoke
so I don't know how this ends I don't
know if this if if
he denies it to the death and he ends up
filing some sort of legal action some
sort of Ethics complaint yeah or he
admits everything
I don't know boy well no matter what I
hope despite chess or not that he's
mentally strong enough for whatever is
to come that's what I keep saying
because I've Been Under Fire right yeah
I can't I can't imagine right like I
just I really can't imagine and maybe we
just have too much compassion but I
don't think so I really just feel like
at the end of the day chess is just a
game
but it is a game played by millions of
people throughout history
and Nations have basically fought Wars
over the chessboard
so like there's there's a lot it's like
Olympics Olympics is just a little oh
this dude running and so on the hockey
is just the thing with for the puck and
but you know
um
it's it's also much more than that it's
also it's also Nations
um
sort of
figuring out their conflict in a way
that doesn't involve violence
that's a serious thing and it's a thing
that inspires
millions of people and it's a testing
ground for intelligent systems that
eventually uh take over human
civilization